[Music]
[Applause]
so we thought
you know what let's bring in somebody
who knows what they're talking about a
former
nfl offensive lineman won a super bowl
with washington
a harvard trained orthopedic dr mark
addicts
and uh good to have you back on here doc
so
do you want us to tell you what we think
turf toe is
and then you could uh probably correct
us on this
that'd be great let's see what you guys
got let's see how good you are all right
i'm gonna start with you paulie
what do you think turf toe is uh like a
ligament sprain
in the toe that hampers an athlete from
pushing off like sprinting like running
all right fritz you got a definition for
turf tone
uh one's toe is so severely sprained
from the pounding on the
turf that it does something where it
kind of disconnects
the toe from the other toes and needs to
be surgically fixed or snapped back into
place
all right seton it is an injury that
when
uh say like wide receivers are going to
get their second foot in
and they drag it along the oh that's
true their toe is on the turf and then
it gets hurt like that that's a turf
tonight
oh i did not i did not look at it that
way yes mcclellan so i thought it was a
rug burn style injury for many times
because those are the worst when you're
playing with your kids a rug burn
but i do believe it's now a ligament
underneath your toe that connects to the
foot
okay let's let's bring in doc and uh doc
what exactly is
turf towel well i think i think uh
example
one wins the ligament injury so it can
be a ligament injury or it can be an
injury to the plantar plate
which is almost like a cartilage thing
that's on the bottom
of the toe it is the big toe joint
and it rarely is an injury that requires
surgery
the vast majority of players don't
require surgery in the nfl
there have been about there was a study
that was done that had about 30 guys
with
turtle injuries that were pretty severe
and only about 10 percent
ended up requiring some surgery deion
sanders did require surgery
dion sanders turtle injury did end his
career essentially
he stuck around for a couple more years
but but never really was the same
antonio gates had had a pretty bad turf
toe
had surgery in 2008 and played many
years was very productive
after that injury and surgery so
generally speaking
guys do okay i think dion was uh as his
foot would attest
was was an extreme case did mahomes play
the super bowl with a torn ligament
yeah certainly he did i mean i i in
other words when you have
a terpto injury there are three grades
grade one grade two grade three
it's the same for almost anything grade
one just a few of the fibers are torn
grade two a bunch more torn grade three
it's completely disruptive
so for someone to need surgery generally
there's got to be a little bone chip
that's in the joint
or the toe has to be somewhat unstable
which would tell you that that ligament
tear
had to be pretty significant what's the
normal timeline for recovery
so i mean the normal timeline for a guy
who who does not require surgery
generally about eight weeks so it's not
short even for guys that don't require
surgery
when you do require surgery it's
generally a four month recovery uh can
go out to six months
four months would make it easy for him
to be back for camp it was six months it
could it could
eat into the start of the season here if
it wasn't the super bowl
do you think he would have been playing
i do
i do i mean i think patrick mahomes is
one of those
guys who cares so much about the team
and his teammates that i think that if
he felt that he could help a team
he would be on the field but does this
last more
is this is this going to be something
that can last like is
could he have done irreparable harm
to this
certainly you can worsen an injury you
can make
the ligament tear worse you can do more
damage to the joint
so is it possible that he him playing in
the afc championship
and the super bowl damaged his joint
further yes that is possible
do i think a well-done surgery should
allow him
to return to the field and be effective
i i expect that i think that that's
how this is going to play out but i
wonder uh if there's more damage there
than just turf toe
if it's the plate itself if if that's
involved in it not to get too deep into
the woods here but
how much more recovery time how much
more
severe is this injury well
sometimes you completely disrupt that
plantar plate sometimes you break
the sesamoid bones there are two little
bones that sit
under that joint as well sometimes you
damage the joints
and there's a little bone chip in the
joint so there are a number of things
that can complicate this but all of them
shouldn't make his recovery extend out
beyond
six months we're finding out dak
prescott had a second surgery
compound fracture and a dislocation here
how like is that normal
and how does that affect him long term
it's not normal um you one
without knowing exactly what the surgery
that was done i mean sometimes they go
in to remove
some of the hardware some of the
hardware is symptomatic
sometimes you go in because people are
so stiff
that they require a procedure to get rid
of some of the scar tissue
so that you can have more normal motion
and sometimes after a big fractured
dislocation like that
you have to go in later to maybe remove
a little bone chip or something
that's irritating the joint so all of
those things are not
good news but um i think he should be
able to return and play
play well as a quarterback you know i
mean if you this if he's a running back
or wide receiver
you know a defensive back i mean it's
it's a much bigger deal
um even though he is a somewhat mobile
quarterback i i think that he should be
able to return and be be the old dac
prescott how much progress have we made
on achilles tears
um there are more minimally
invasive procedures that are out there
now that i think are pretty darn
effective
i think that the rehab has become um
appropriately aggressive and so i think
folks do better now
with achilles ruptures than they did a
decade ago and i think some of it's due
to the the
more minimally invasive surgery and some
of it's due to the
to the more aggressive we have uh i'm
going to open this up to the danettes do
you guys have a
a sports related question injury-wise
for a doctor addicts here
because i i had the micro fracture
surgery of my knee
and uh it didn't work but i had six
operations i eventually got a
replacement knee are they still doing
micro fracture
surgery where they take the drill and go
whip it into your knee
um it's much more rarely done it is sort
of a last-ditch shepherd
in a younger patient to try to get some
new cartilage to grow just so you know
i uh in the exact same boat i had micro
fracture
a few more surgeries and i have a total
needs here now so
um yeah so the result yeah i was
resolved after micro fracture uh
my career was never the same after that
uh do you guys have
this is free medical advice so if you
want to take uh doc up on this if you
got a question here mclovin do you have
a question
i'll start so i have a hip impingement
doc uh
am i making it worse by running uh i jog
am i making it worse and will i
eventually need a hip replacement
because i have a hip impingement
in my right hip all right all right so i
am 59 years old i haven't weighed less
than 300 pounds in forever both my hips
i have impingement
i mean i avoid positions uh that cause
me pain right
most men have fai
or femoroacetabular impingement and it
does not
necessarily mean that you're going to
need a joint replacement now
i mean as we age sometimes we have to
change what we do
and maybe need to go from running to a
bike or running to an elliptical or
you know change it up a little bit cross
train a little bit but no i wouldn't
tell you to necessarily
go and have a hip scope to have that
impingement removed because who knows if
that will actually make you better
you could end up like dan here and have
four more surgeries and then a hip
replacement
seat no counter about four years ago
when the super bowl was in houston
we went and shot a bit where uh all of
us were went to a spin class
and it was funny because we're all out
of shape or most of us are out of shape
okay i was out of shape
and while we were doing that when we
were done sometime later that night
my right knee exploded and was like four
times the size it normally is
and i couldn't walk right for about two
or three weeks and now every time that i
go do something whether it's running or
like play soccer with my kid or
something uh my knee swells up again
do you think there's something wrong
there
so you were
um so you were up and you were up and
out of the saddle and you know really
really grinding going after it did you
win did you win
out of all the nets were you the winner
i sure was not
no he was not no do you think he needs
uh
surgery do you think there's mri
well all right so when that happens it's
usually you're grinding some of the
cartilage off the ends of your bone
little pieces of cartilage flake off the
joint gets irritated
and swells up and so now when you're
running around playing with the kids
this continues to happen so i mean an
mri would show you whether this was
a meniscus tear or more cartilage injury
um very
often we have these injections i call
them an oil change it's hyaluronic acid
and it's uh it's like an oil change for
the joint and sometimes that can
help protect the cartilage and calm the
joint down but
it sounds like you're you've got some
wear and tear in there for sure uh
paulie uh dr addicts i was throwing some
weight around last year in the
weight room and like my elbow where the
joint is if i put my arm straight out
it's the top like the ligament or
whatever it is at the top of the joint
and to hold stuff like in your hand it
hurts a lot and
rest ice all that stuff didn't help
whatsoever what are your thoughts
sounds like tennis elbow um if you if
you stand up and grab a chair and try to
pick up a chair by the back of a chair
how does that feel
horrendous okay yeah it's tennis elbow
so
the the medical term is lateral
epicondylitis go to your orthopedic
surgeon let me give you a cortisone
injection you'll be cured
and uh we'll save the worst for last
todd yeah i got a lot of problems
the uh the bottoms of my feet i went to
a podiatrist recently but i want to hear
what you have to say
right before right under the toes i feel
like i'm walking on a bump or like
there's a sock
stuffed in my shoe and i'm not sure
what's going on he suggested eventually
i may need
physical therapy or needles but what is
this bump across
right under my toes where it feels like
i'm walking on like a little mini
pictures mound
you know i mean usually that's
metatarsalgia so the better question is
do you feel worse barefoot or do you
feel worse with shoes on
i feel worse with shoes on and he sold
me these uh you know little insoles to
put in and
it told me to ice my feet which it
hasn't uh worked
just yet so i'm trying to figure out to
avoid needles what uh
if it feels if it feels worse with shoes
on then that usually means you have an
aroma so that when the bones are pressed
together by a shoe
it's it's irritating a nerve and that
nerve grows and makes a little you know
it gets a little swollen
so those neuromas usually they give you
a metatarsal pad
and then so that spreads the toes apart
and sometimes they can do an injection
to shrink that nerve
and the worst case scenario they can do
a surgery and actually go in
and remove that nerve so it doesn't feel
like that anymore would you be willing
to do a surgery here in the man cave on
one of the den at stock
you know i think we could pull that off
you know with some local anesthetic and
a bullet to bite on i think i think we
can pull it off
do you realize that one of my when i got
the micro fracture knee surgery
my doctor said you want to watch me do
it and he was going to give me a local
and i could watch in the monitor and i
said are you
crazy and he said well a lot of people
don't want to be put under
because of the anesthesia and then you
get nauseous when you wake up
he said this is just a local and you
could watch me
send a drill bit through your knee
do you do this do you do you allow
people to stay away
i don't i don't uh you know i actually
did stay awake for one of my surgeries
when i was a resident and i was actually
training to be an orthopedic surgeon i
watched one of mine
but with my patients i just think it i
did it a few times and i had patients
that
basically never quit talking the entire
case
and it was a distraction and so i i i
just put them to sleep now
why is every surgery a successful
surgery on an athlete
um i call it the beautiful baby syndrome
you know i mean
we do a surgery and that's our baby you
know no one's gonna say their baby
[Laughter]
but everybody's surgery is a successful
surgery it feels like
yeah yeah we should have our hands
bronzed after every case
and do you make your uh patients put
like uh this is the need that you're
going to operate on like i had to take a
sharpie and i had to
actually write my initials on it just so
they asked me like six times uh are we
doing your left knee yeah yes and then i
go god these guys are incompetent they
don't know what need that they're doing
they wanted me legally to keep saying no
it's my left knee
all right here's a sharpie we want you
to write your initials on the knee that
we're going to cut on
is that normal no every every case
the patient and the surgeon have to
write with a sharpie on the knee
and you're going to be asked by every
single nurse and every anesthesiologist
i mean it's the worst case scenario
right i mean if you operate on the wrong
extremity
you know it's write him a check did you
ever do there's no defense
did you ever do that did you hear yeah
[Laughter]
hey doc always great to talk to you we
appreciate your time i hope you're well
you bet thanks for having me on dad
thanks guys dr mark addicts a
former super bowl champ with washington